diferencias entre mejores amigos Israel
no recibió bien los comentarios del
presidente de Estados Unidos sobre el
polémico proyecto de reforma judicial
Joe biden recomendó el martes a la
administración de Benjamín netanyahu no
continuar por el mismo camino dijo que
no quería interferir pero que Israel ya
conocía su postura y que te la DIF
debería encontrar un consenso lo más
pronto posible
conozco el presidente biden desde hace
más de 40 años y a precios o compromiso
de larga Data con Israel la alianza
entre Israel y Estados Unidos es
inquebrantable y siempre superadas
eventuales diferencias entre nosotros y
Israel es un país soberano que toma sus
decisiones por voluntad de su pueblo y
no basado en presiones externas incluso
de los mejores amigos este miércoles la
Casa Blanca insistió una vez más en su
mensaje
Israel es una democracia y un estado
soberano Por supuesto que los estados
soberanos toman decisiones soberanas
Pero obviamente instamos a los líderes
israelíes a llegar a un compromiso lo
antes posible los comentarios del
presidente byden ayer Sobre alejarse de
la Reforma son perfectamente conscientes
con la búsqueda de un compromiso que
preserva el control y el equilibrio de
Israel
y mientras hay tensión diplomática las
calles de Israel presencia en el
descontento de los manifestantes Pese a
que el proyecto legislativo se detuvo a
principios de esta semana decenas de
ciudadanos protestaron en Jerusalén y
tel aviv en unas movilizaciones en las
que ahora también rechazan la propuesta
para la creación de una Guardia nacional
que estaría bajo el control del ministro
de seguridad el ultraderechista y Tamara
en el pasado benjivir ha sido acusado de
apoyar a un grupo terrorista y de
incitar al racismo entre tanto la
coalición de gobierno y la oposición
tendrían por delante varios meses para
tratar de llegar a un acuerdo sobre la
controvertida reforma judicial